okay we're gonna move on from Trump's
very boring and sweaty and low energy
announcement that he's running for
president it really was sort of like I'm
running for president all right okay
well let's move on
um even Fox News cut away from the
speech and they didn't go back to it for
a while this is super interesting at a
certain point during the speech which
was expected to be under a half hour
Trump went an hour and ranted and raved
about executing drug dealers and so many
other different things when Trump
started talking about Angela Merkel
Fox News just straight up cut away his
friend Sean Hannity cutting away
remember I sent to
Angela remember Angela do you remember
Uncle nobody's remembering her now I'm
going to be just joining us president
Trump and Mar-A-Lago announcing his 2024
presidential run yeah so Hannity cutting
away that was at 9 40 p.m eastern time
at 9 44 p.m as you can see here they
still hadn't come back they were
interviewing Mike Huckabee
and that looks like Pete hegseth and
then at 9 46 p.m they also didn't come
back they were interviewing Jim Jordan
and
um oh I forgot the name of this woman
who was uh the great Alan Combs
sister-in-law I forget her name that was
at 9 46 p.m and then at 9 48 p.m they
were interviewing some guy I don't
recognize and Leo Terrell wearing a Leo
2.0 hat this is not a good sign for
Donald Trump and there was a story
floating around yesterday that the
Murdoch's and Fox News are totally off
the Trump train it was one of these
speculative but unconfirmed stories but
interestingly enough this morning early
this morning Maria Bartiromo by far one
of the biggest brown-nosers of Donald
Trump now for years who spread Trump's
conspiracy theories and everything even
Maria Bartiromo this morning potentially
after seeing the level of lack of energy
rather at yesterday's speech Maria
bartiroma hosted a panel all of whom
were criticizing Trump and saying a lot
of the stuff Trump is pulling were over
as Republicans take a look at this
that's that's the thing that people keep
pushing back on they don't want to go
into a whole nother storm of hate and
there is Trump derangement syndrome
right there's definitely and and I think
he started even that last night he
started with the China virus he started
with you know poking names at DeSantis
we've heard that and people are tired of
it look I also think wow that you know
DeSantis and young and like you said are
really the future of the party right
they're in a generation that I think
needs to come forward and as much as you
know his policies were good Trump's
office is in the first in the first term
I don't think the majority of the
country really wants to go back there
I'll tell you I live in Florida Florida
is fully behind the scientist no matter
what Trump wants to tell you they are
fully behind the scientist you know
what's interesting Ivanka Trump Ivanka
Trump yesterday says she's bowing out of
politics just after her father's
announcement uh the former first
daughter telling Fox and she'll be
staying out of the political Arena all
together yeah
so um this really is fascinating because
at the end of the day you you almost
start wondering
how did Trump even end up running
because the polling has shifted
dramatically towards DeSantis who isn't
even running for anything at this point
not even all of Trump's family wants him
to do this Ivanka not even there she's
bowing out you know I love my father
butt sort of stuff
Maria Bartiromo seems to now be
regularly entertaining anti-trump guests
Fox News has started to do man on the
street interviews where they happen to
come across Republicans who want
DeSantis to be the nominee rather than
Donald Trump the New York Post also a
news corporation product puts out Trump
de Dumpty covers last week making fun of
Donald Trump you start to wonder who
around Trump actually wants him to do
this
and where you end up is it really does
seem like the guy has no friends other
than his own ego and this is all
directed by his own ego and it is going
to be I mean listen I'll say it it's
going to be an interesting two years it
also may be sort of a sad two years
it'll be good for the country of trump
uh uh crashes and burns
but it also may have some level of
sadness but let's not assume like we did
in 2015 and 2016 that Trump can't win
because it is very early it is very
early Anything Can Happen DeSantis
hasn't even announced anything and will
look at the polling a little bit later
in the show in the meantime
support the independent Progressive
media that you like if it's this show
make sure you're subscribed on YouTube
it's free make sure you're subscribed to
the podcast it's free if you want sign
up at joinpakman.com if you prefer Sam
cedar or The Young Turks or Brian Tyler
Cohen or whoever just make sure you're
supporting the infrastructure so that we
are well placed and well prepared not to
let let any of these extremists whether
it's DeSantis or Trump or whoever
actually win in 2024. we'll take a quick
break and then be right back
good habits have to be sustainable in
order to become habits it has to be
something you'll actually do and when it
comes to nutrition some people have
hours to plan out every meal their exact
vitamin intake I'm not doing any of that
I don't have the time here's what's
sustainable for me I start my day with
just a single scoop of ag-1 from
athletic greens it gives me the entire
day's worth of the 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics I want
from whole food sources it's just simple
it's just one scoop of ag1 I get all the
nutrients I want I don't have to do any
math use my protractor my TI-83 or take
a bunch of different capsules and pills
it's not some kind of wacky supplement
making a bunch of crazy claims you know
I would not promote something like that
ag1 is just a simple product it does
what it says it does it gives you the
daily nutrients and vitamins you likely
want vitamin A C E magnesium zinc
potassium in one simple scoop you keep
your body nourished you'll also get a
free year supply of vitamin D which I
take in the winter plus five free travel
packs at athleticgreens.com Pacman the
link is down below